200000 c'est le nombre de personnes
présentes à Cannes pendant le festival
habituellement la ville ne compte que
74000 habitants pour les Cinéfil Cann
c'est le paradis imaginez plutôt 83 long
métrages seront projetés cette année en
sélection officielle mais également
pendant la quinzaine des réalisateurs et
la Semaine de la Critique Jean Bo est un
passionné de cinéma originaire de
basemont il a relié les ivelines à Cann
en
vélo en général pour venir à can on
prend le train ou l'avion des festivals
je BO jeune retraité de 62 ans est venu
en vélo en 8 jours avec son vélo à
assistance électrique et sa remorque il
a parcouru 1200 km j'ai souffert un peu
de pluie simplement les deux premiers
jours mais ensuite ça s'est relativement
très bien déroulé y compris même le vent
dans la vallée du rô qui me poussait ver
can donc en fait j'avais la facilité de
pouvoir descendre plus facilement avec
des vitesses relativement tranquille
sans bien forcer sans forcément mettre
en plus l'assistance électrique en
fonction et si je déplacement de
basemont à Cann pendant le festival
c'est bien pour le plaisir d'aller voir
des films rendez-vous au restaurant
jeanvé est entouré de sa femme Martine
et deux de leurs amis Catherine et Angel
à table il débrief les films qu'ils ont
vu et prépare le programme de la journée
hisire belle histoire super images et
cet après-midi on va voir
donc tablea un Indonésien ces passionné
de cinéma se sont fixé un objectif aller
voir jusqu'à trois films par jour et
quand il s'agit de chois s je est plutôt
genre à se reposer sur les filles les
filles ont travaillé sur le programme
là moi j'étaisé hier à 20h j'étais piqué
une tête dans l'eau on m'a même demandé
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs si l'eau était
froide je dit B non même plutôt chaude m
ma là en fin de journée participeré au
festival de canne jean-y savour sa
chance voici le précieux sésame ce badge
qui lui permet d'assister gratuitement
aux séances pour l'obtenir il a dû
s'inscrire en début d'année on écrit en
fait une lre de motivation
la direction fait du Festival de Cannes
qui elle en fait va nous permettre
d'obtenir alors il y a un nombre assez
conséquent de de SESAM qui qui sont
distribués à savoir 4000 4000 places
donc ça laisse en fait beaucoup de de
possibilités pour tous les canois et
puis d'autres personnes en fait d'être
invité et d'avoir la possibilité dans le
cadre de can cinéphil de pouvoir
assister à toutes ces toutes ces
projections installé confortablement
dans son fauteuil Jean y est maintenant
prêt à être plongé dans une nouvelle
aventure c'est une découverte c'est
surtout en fait quelque chose qui est
complètement différent de la télévision
puisque en fait on a un grand écran on
est dans une salle sombre on a le son
qui arrive de tous les côtés et c'est en
fait une manière aussi de justement de
de s'inclure dans le film et puis de se
presque de se retrouver au travers de
l'écran c'est sincèrement un réel
plaisir de s'isoler là pendant pendant 2
he ou un peu moins de 2 he sur la
projection pour pouvoir réellement
communier avec le film La lumière
s'éteint dans la salle place à la magie
du cinéma iici la fin du festival Jean
Yve Martine Angel et Catherine espèr
avoir vu jusqu'à 40 films 40 histoires
et autant de souvenirs et d'avis à
partagé en
[Musique]
rentrant